pineapple way of testing is nice and
ripe top of the leaves come out perfect
ready to go always cut the pineapple
with a serrated edge knife slice off the
bottom turn it back over and slice the
top part now keep that for later look at
the core the center of the pineapple and
slice now directly in half slice that in
half take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible lay down flat just
slice that core off so you got this
perfect sort of boat like pineapple
slice underneath but stop as you get
right at the end slicing around the skin
will make the pineapple easier to eat
but leaving it at ass
gives you more control as it cooks next
please a griddle pan as hot as you can
start off in the corner and push it down
so you really mark the pineapple two
minutes on each side
and then just turn them a really nice
color
oh that beautiful I'm gonna sprinkle
them with a little touch of sugar that's
gonna glaze them now slice the top take
out these beautiful glazed slices of
pineapple
next up the spiced caramel now start off
with your pan nice and hot
sprinkle four tablespoons of sugar in
there just flatten it then have the
seeds from a fresh vanilla pod in a
small dusting of Chinese five-spice
never stir camel let it sort of bubble
and transform and she goes now I've got
the color I want it that's the perfect
color off with the gas in with a butter
then couple tablespoons of cream lovely
and give that a little whisk add the
rest of your cream nice and just
trip a spicy camel over your pineapple
hmm Wow simple elegant and seriously
impressive briddle pineapple with spiced
camel a delicious treat all to yourself
that tastes even better shared that
makes the fish cake
nice and fragrant touch of salt
naki loves fresh pepper
so pepper in